♪
>> Ben: FOR THE PAST HALF
CENTURY, THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA HAS DOMINATED THE
CATEGORY NO ONE WOULD EVER WANT
TO OWN.
WE HAVE, AS A NATION, ONE OF THE
MOST RADICAL ABORTION REGIMES IN
THE WORLD.
IT MIGHT SURPRISE TO YOU FOR
THIS.
YOU CERTAINLY WON'T HEAR IT FROM
ANYONE ON ANY OTHER NETWORK.
BUT THAT SUPPOSEDLY EXTREME
MISSISSIPPI LAW HEADED FOR THE
SUPREME COURT WHICH WOULD BLOCK
MOST ABORTIONS AFTER 15 WEEKS
WOULD BE RIGHT AT HOME IN EUROPE
WHEN ALL THOSE NATIONS THE LEFT
WANTS TO EMULATE AND OTHER AREAS
OF POLICY LIKE FRANCE AND SWEDEN
BAN ABORTION.
IN FACT, ALL THE COUNTRIES YOU
SEE ON YOUR SCREEN BAN ELECTIVE
ABORTION AT 12 WEEKS.
NONE OF THEM HAVE WHAT AMERICA
EFFECTIVELY HAS IN MANY STATES
ABORTION UP TO THE POINT OF
BIRTH.
FOR THAT, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
OUR MORAL EQUALS IN NATIONS LIKE
CHINA OR NORTH KOREA.
WHY IS IT THAT AMERICA HAS
PERSISTED IN THIS EXTREME REGIME
EVEN AS THE REST OF THE WORLD
WOKE UP TO THE MORAL REALITY OF
WHAT ABORTION DOES TO FAMILIES
AND SOCIETIES.
IT'S A COMPLICATED STORY BUT
IT'S ALSO VERY SIMPLE, REALLY.
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN WILLING TO
LOOK THE OTHER WAY IN A VAST
INDUSTRY OF POWERFUL FORCES IN
OUR COUNTRY HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO.
UNDERSTAND THERE IS NO MORE
IMPORTANT SINGLE ISSUE TODAY TO
THE LEFT THAN THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION.
IT IS AN ITEM OF FAITH THEY ARE
WEDDED TO STRONGER THAN ANY
RELIGIOUS CONVICTION.
IF YOU HAVE EVER BEEN TAKEN
ABACK BY THE VITRIOL VIOLENCE
AND FALSE ACCUSATIONS LEVELED
AGAINST ANY WHO CHALLENGE
ABORTION YOU WILL KNOW WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
THE KIND THAT MAKES A YOUNG
WOMAN SPIT ON AN ELDERLY PRIEST.
IT'S SAFER TO SACK CRINGE IN A
THREEDDLE THAN ABORTION RALLIES.
PLACE YOURSELF AT ODDS NOT JUST
WITH THE MOST POWERFUL ACTIVIST
GROUPINGS AND DONORS, TO TAKE ON
THE WOKE CORPORATIST AND
HOLLYWOOD AND OUR CORRUPT MEDIA
AND BIG TECH WELL, JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY WITH POWER IN AMERICA
TODAY.
SINCE THE MOMENT ROE V. WADE
SHORT CIRCUITED THE LEGAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT ABORTION THE
PRO-ABORTION LEFT HAS WORKED TO
GASLIGHT THE COUNTRY INTO
BELIEVING THINGS THAT JUST
AREN'T TRUE.
THEY PRETENDED THEY WANTED
ABORTIONS TO BE RARE.
THEY CLAIMED THEY DIDN'T PROFIT
FROM THEM.
THEY DENIED THEY SOLD ORGANS.
THEY REFUSED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SCIENCE OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
UNBORN BABIES.
UNKNOWN TO THE AUTHORS OF ROE BY
THE WAY.
THE IGNORED THE TERRIBLE AND
TRAGIC IMPACT ON THE POOREST AND
MOST VULNERABLE FAMILIES AND ON
THE BLACK FAMILY IN PARTICULAR.
MORE BLACK FAMILIES ARE ABORTED
THAN BORN IN NEW YORK CITY EVERY
YEAR AND THAT'S FINE WITH THEM.
THEY ALSO DID EVERYTHING THEY
COULD TO BUILD UP MEN LIKE BILL
CLINTON AND ANDREW CUOMO BECAUSE
THE ABORTION AGENDA IS ALWAYS
MORE IMPORTANT.
WHY DO YOU THINK JOE BIDEN
FLIPPED ON THE HYDE AMENDMENT
AND TAXPAYER FUNDED ABORTIONS
AFTER AN ENTIRE CAREER OF SAYING
HE BELIEVED THE OPPOSITE?
EVERY SUNDAY HIS HEAD BOWED IN
HIS CHURCH HE KNOWS WHO RUNS THE
LEFT.
HE WANTED TO BE PRESIDENT AND HE
WAS WILLING TO MAKE A DEAL TO DO
IT.
AND IN EVERY ASPECT OF THIS
EFFORT, THE PRO-ABORTION LEFT
HAS HAD THE STRONG ADVOCACY OF A
MEDIA THAT HAS DISPLAYED MORE
CORRUPTION ON THIS TOPIC THAN,
PERHAPS, ANY OTHER.
IF YOU WATCH ABC, NBC, OR CBS
TODAY, PRO-LIFE WOMEN SIMPLY DO
NOT EXIST.
THE MEDIA'S COVERAGE OF THIS
ISSUE IS INTIS DISTINGUISHABLE
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD PRESS
RELEASES AND JOURNALISTS
COVERING IT NOT JUST UNIVERSALLY
PRO-CHOICE BUT OBVIOUSLY
PRO-ABORTION.
BUT NOW AT LONG LAST, SOMETHING
IS HAPPENING.
THE ENERGY IN THE PRO-LIFE
MOVEMENT IS LIKE NOTHING WE HAVE
EVER SEEN BEFORE.
ABORTION IS NO LONGER ACCEPTED
AS AN UNOBJECTIONABLE GOOD.
THE SHOUT YOUR ABORTION MOVEMENT
WHERE WOMEN ARE ENCOURAGED BY
THE ABORTION LOBBY TO BOAST
ABOUT KILL THEIR CHILDREN COMES
ACROSS AS DESPERATE AND SAD.
DECADES OF ULTRASOUND PICTURES
ON REFRIGERATORS AND WOMEN BRAVE
ENOUGH TO TALK ABOUT MISCARRIAGE
AND LOSS HAVE A WAY OF CHANGING
MINDS.
WHEN ICELAND SAYS THEY HAVE
ERADICATED DOWN SYNDROME GOOD
PEOPLE CRINGE BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS.
>> I AM A MAN.
SEE ME AS A HUMAN BEING.
NOT A BIRTH DEFECT.
NOT A SYNDROME.
I DON'T NEED TO BE IRRADICATED.
I DON'T NEED TO BE CURED.
>> Ben: WHEN NAIVE EVIDENTISTS
REGULARLY SUGGEST THAT
PRO-LIFERS LIKE CHILDREN SO
MUCH, MAYBE WE SHOULD FORCE THE
DADS TO PAY CHILD SUPPORT FOR
UNBORN BABIES.
OUR RESPONSE IS YOUR TERMS ARE
ACCEPTABLE.
THERE IS TODAY RENEWED HOPE
AMONG THOSE WHO BELIEVE EVERY
UNBORN BABY HAS A RIGHT TO LIFE,
THAT THE SUPREME COURT MAY AT
LONG LAST WE OPEN THE
SIGNIFICANT QUESTION FOR US TO
DECIDE AS CITIZENS AND STATES
INSTEAD OF LEAVING THE DEEPEST
MORAL QUESTION OF LIFE AND DEATH
TO NINE PEOPLE IN ROBES.
TONIGHT I'M GOING TO BE TALKING
TO A NUMBER OF HEROIC PRO-LIFE
WOMEN WHO BROUGHT US TO THIS
MOMENT.
THEIR DETERMINED WORK IN LAW AND
POLITICS AND CULTURE IS
ABSOLUTELY THE REASON WE ARE AT
THIS POINT SO MANY OF US
DESPAIRED AND ONCE THOUGHT
IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY HAVE TAKEN ON THE GOLIATH
OF THE ABORTION INDUSTRY AND ALL
ITS VILE WORKS WITH FEARLESS
DEDICATION TO BE A VOICE FOR THE
VOICELESS.
MUCH OF THE DISCUSSION AROUND
ABORTION IS ABOUT THE LAW.
AND, OF COURSE, WE WILL TALK
ABOUT THAT TONIGHT.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER LAW I WANT
YOU TO CONSIDER AS YOU LISTEN
AND THAT IS THE LAW WRITTEN ON
YOUR HEARTS.
BACK IN 1933, LONG BEFORE ROE,
WHITAKER CHAMBERS WAS WORKING AS
A SOVIET AGENT WHEN HIS WIFE
FOUND OUT SHE WAS PREGNANT.
DESPITE THE INITIAL JOY BOTH
KNEW SUCH THINGS WERE NOT
POSSIBLE.
WIFE WENT TO SEE A DOCTOR MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS.
WHEN SHE CAME BACK SHE WAS QUIET
AND NONCOMMITTAL IT SLOWLY
DAWNED ON CHAMBERS SHE WANTED TO
KEEP THE CHILD.
HE ASKED HER HE'S WRITES IN HIS
AUTOBIOGRAPHY WITNESS MY WIFE
CAME OVER TO ME TOOK MY HANDS
AND BURST INTO TEARS.
DEAR HEART SHE SAID IN A
PLEADING VOICE, WE COULDN'T DO
THAT AWFUL THING TO A LITTLE
BABY NOT LITTLE BABY DEAR HEART.
A REASON, THE AGONY OF MY FAMILY
THE COMMUNIST COMMUNIST
THEORIES, THE WARS OF
REVOLUTIONS FOR 20TH CENTURY
CRUMBLED AT THE TOUCH OF A
CHILD.
WHAT WE ARE DISCUSSING TONIGHT
IS THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION
FOR US, WHETHER THE UNBORN LIVES
THAT TAKE ROOT HERE IN AMERICA
ARE UNIQUE PERSONS WITH THE
RIGHT TO DRAW BREATH AND BLOSSOM
OR WHETHER THEY ARE NONPERSONS,
LIVES UNWORTHY OF LIFE, HUMAN
WEEDS AS PLANNED PARENTHOOD
MARGARET SANGER CALLED THEM
WHOSE DESTRUCTION IS A PUBLIC
GOOD.
THE MISSION THAT TELLS US TO
DESTROY A LIFE IS TO DESTROY A
WHOLE WORLD.
THE WORLDS THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
WITH THAT LIFE MEANT.
LOOK TO HEART, YOU KNOW THIS TO
BE TRUE.
I'M BEN DOMENECH AND THIS IS THE
AMER